- What's up, y'all?
We're back and our next guest stars
in the Peabody-nominated
Netflix series created
by Mindy Kaling it's
called "Never Have I Ever."
Check it out?
(gentle music)
- Is this a head shot?
Wow LA trash is depressing.
- I know.
I think I saw a silicone breast implant.
- Wow.
- So about yesterday.
I thought about what you said
and I'm in.
I'd like to be your girlfriend.
As long as we don't kill each other,
I think it could be really nice.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
(audience applauds)
- All right, y'all.
Please say hello to Jaren Lewison.
(audience cheers)
I wish I could hug you, I know.
It's nice to meet you.
- It's so good to meet you too.
Thank you for having me.
Hey, everybody.
- I'm so excited.
I love having fellow Texans
on here.
- Oh my God.
I know.
Me too.
- Yeah.
Where were you born in Texas?
- Yeah, so I was born in north Dallas
and I actually lived
there most of my life,
but I'm not like a super country boy.
I'm definitely more of a city kid.
But if it counts,
my school did have a
country Western dance team.
- If it counts? (laughs)
- Yeah, if that`gives
me any country points.
- We line dance.
It is funny though, because I
tell people anytime I'm like,
"Oh, I'm from Fort Worth.
"I was born in Fort Worth,"
they'll be like, "Oh I've been to Dallas."
And I'm like, "That's really different."
- Kinda different for sure.
Not super close either.
- It's really different.
Yeah, I mean, I know that we're like,
you know, 30 minutes apart,
but it is funny because
I do feel like people are more city.
Like I think like Fort Worth now
it's more of a metropolis
from whenever I grew up there.
'Cause I'm like a lot older than you,
(man laughs)
but I just mean it's different now,
but no, it is very much the
opposite side of the tracks,
but I love Dallas.
- Yeah, it is.
- They have great food.
- Yeah, the food's so good.
Fort Worth actually.
I love Fort Worth.
- The arts festival.
They have like a cool stuff
in that town.
- Yeah.
Well my favorite barbecue
places in Fort Worth.
- [Kelly] Oh, what is it?
- Have you ever been to Cooper's barbecue?
- [Kelly] No.
- Okay so it's in Fort Worth.
- I haven't
lived there in a minute.
- Okay.
Do you know where Billy Bob's is?
- Have I performed there?
Yes (laughs).
- Of course, of course.
- I love Billy Bob's, yeah.
- I've never gotten to go to Billy Bob's
but right next door is Cooper's.
- Oh.
- It's my favorite barbecue place.
I always judge barbecue by the brisket
and then they're famous for the rib eye.
So if you ever go like Kelly,
I'm telling you it's unreal.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- It's so good.
- I love it.
Okay.
Well speaking of food,
I have yet to find a good queso this city.
Have you?
- No, no.
Kelly, if you find good queso,
literally I'll drive an hour.
- Yes.
- [Jaren] I can't find it.
- Also cream cheese with salsa.
What?
It's real good.
- I've actually
never tried it.
- You should do it
and you're welcome.
- [Jaren] Okay.
- Trust Texans.
We like food.
So what's new in season
two of "Never Have I Ever"?
- Yeah.
So season one if you guys haven't seen,
it's based on events
from Mindy Kaling's life
and it centers around Devi Vishwakumar,
who is played by Maitreyi Ramakrishnan.
And it basically goes through high school
and it's got so many
different types of characters
and so much diversity within it.
So for season two,
we really dive into kind
of the complexities of those characters.
Everybody has something in season two
that's so interesting and
complex and different.
We have, you know,
different identity crisis's
and people are finding
themselves in different ways.
You have family dynamics.
And for me, for Ben Gross my character,
if you guys haven't seen season one,
I would skip this next 20 seconds,
but it ends with me, Ben Gross,
and Devi making out in a car.
So it's, you know,
been coming for all of these years.
They've really been getting closer
and season two dives into-
- It's pressure.
- Yeah.
They dive into more of that
relationship and kind of,
you know, different aspects
of their blossoming romance
and all that kind of stuff.
It's a wild ride.
So I would definitely say that y'all have
to tune in to find out 'cause
there's some pretty crazy stuff, y'all.
- There's some pretty
crazy stuff (chuckles).
- I mean it.
I don't want to spoil it
too much but you know?
- I have to ask though.
Is it nerveracking?
Like the first time you
kissed someone onscreen?
Is it as nerveracking
as it is in real life?
- You know, it's like a
different kind of nerves.
Like my first kiss in
real life, coincidentally,
they were both in a car.
My first kiss in real life and on screen.
- That's also very Texan.
- Yeah, I know.
My mom, no chance.
I was not gonna be in my house for that.
But I was in a car and I was so nervous
that like the girl I was with,
I think she leaned in 90%
and I maybe had the last 10.
And like, as we were kissing,
I was thinking to myself-
- You didn't even meet her halfway?
- Oh my God, no too nervous.
Yeah, no, I was like,
I can't get like that.
- I love it.
- I was literally just staring like this.
Just like I couldn't even look
at her 'cause I was so scared.
- Oh, I love that.
- 'Cause I like didn't
know what I was doing.
- Yeah, yeah it's awkward.
_ I remember
thinking like while we were kissing,
like how do you breathe?
- Yeah, and why are you searching
for something in the back of
my throat with your tongue?
- Yes!
I was like, what is going on right now?
- Yeah, it's a lot of tongue action.
I hated my first kiss.
- Mine was actually pretty solid.
- Mine was not.
I'm so jealous.
- Really?
- Yeah it was not good.
- Okay.
Well I'm sorry to hear that.
- Yeah.
- But you know, my first
onscreen kiss was great though.
I felt like besides the 45 people
that are watching you and making it like,
oh hey crew, what's going on?
It's for the most part, I
felt like it was really calm.
It was really you know, intimate
even though there's a
lot of people around.
I felt like for our characters,
it was such a big moment.
And I think that it really translated
how comfortable we felt and the tone.
You know I felt like
it was really correct.
And it just it made me
feel really confident
and excited because I felt
like so many of the fans like loved it.
It created this love triangle
with team Paxton and team Ben.
And it's just it was super exciting
to be able to kind of pull that off.
- I guess it's kind of easier because you
are playing a character.
So it's like, this is
how my character kisses.
- Yeah, for sure.
So like if you're bad, it's like,
oh that's the character.
- Yeah, that's the character.
- It's definitely not me.
- You should see my real work
in real life.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Well everybody, "Never Have I Ever,"
returns this month to Netflix.